all right a quick little demonstration
showing that when the temperature of a
ball goes down its pressure goes down
and we're gonna use a basketball because
basketballs are really nice you don't
need up a pressure gauge in order to
measure the pressure of a basketball
because the pressure determines how high
it will bounce of the pressure is high
the ball will bounce high the pressure
is low a little bounce much lower now
this is a room-temperature ball no
Sophie if you can come down low I'm
sorry and run to the refrigerator where
we have an identical ball that we put it
in the fridge for a couple of hours the
only difference is that this balls
temperature is much lower than the room
temperature one here's the little
demonstration so hold that and you're
right in and nice and steady
well this one over here and kind of
three drop them together one same height
two three and you see that the group
temperature ball bounced much higher
than this called one over here and that
shows that the pressure in the cold one
has gone down you can see this more
dramatically from a higher release of
the two balls so there you go the room
temperature ball bounced much higher
again than the cold one shown that the
pressure of the cold one is going down
all right that's all from the de green
science at times at home yeah alright
see ya